[موسيقى]
مساء الخير على حضراتكم احنا بنتابع ما
يجري في غزه بعين على الاحداث ما يجري
تفاصيل المعارك تفاصيل الاحداث اليوميه
وعين اخرى على مستقبل غزه والمستقبل ده
بيجري الترتيب اليه من الايام الاولى
للحرب الولايات المتحده اسرائيل دول
اوروبيه دول عربيه
بتتشاكل مستقبل غزه وكثير من هذه
السيناريوهات بيركز على مستقبل غزه في حال
اختفاء حماس او خساره حماس للحرب عن
مستقبل غزه والترتيبات الدوليه لهذا
المستقبل بستيف الاستاذ الدكتور احمد يوسف
احمد استاذ العلاقات الدوليه علشان يوضح
لنا ما يجري وما قد يجري في الشهور
القليله
القادمه مساء الخير مع الدكتور الاول مساء
النور السيناريوهات
المطروحه مرفوضه ولن يحدث الا ان تعيد
تكرار ما حدث في طوفان الاقصى ولو بعد حين
لنناقش
هذه السيناريوهات اول سيناريو ان يكون
هناك حكم خانع موالي تابع لاسرائيل وهذا
مستحيل اذا كانت اسرائيل تريد عملاء
فلسطينيين يحكموا غزه بالنيابه عنها فلن
تجد كده صراحه واي فلسطيني سيقبل ان يحكم
غزه او غير غزه لصالح اسرائيل مصيره معروف
يبقى السيناريو الاول ان تتولى اسرائيل
رغما عن
انفها القضيه الامن واداره قطاع غزه وهنا
سيكون الفشل الذريع الفشل الذريع لان هي
اوجدت من المعطيات في غزه غير المقاومه
الفلسطينيه اوجدت مسؤوليات هائله لن تتمكن
كقوه احتلال من الوفاء بها فاول سيناريو
هو السيناريو الاسرائيلي طبعا انا ربما
فاتني ان اقول ان هناك سيناريو شرير اخر
يسبق هذا نخلي غزه اصلا يعني وهذا
السيناريو الحمد لله بفضل موقف
الفلسطينيين اولا المتمسكين بارضهم وبفضل
موقف مصر والاردن الرافضين تماما لسيناريو
التهجير ليس كما يقولون لان مصر او الاردن
يخافون من قدوم مليون او 2 مليون مصر بسم
الله ما شاء الله فيها حوالي 10 مليون
عربي القضيه ان هذا السيناريو يعني الق
قبول بتصفيه القضيه الفلسطينيه فقبل
الاداره الاسرائيليه او اداره عميله
لاسرائيل تحكم غزه كان هناك سيناريو
التهجير والحمد لله انه تم اسقاطه ولو
مؤقتا لان انا احذر من انه البعض القوى
المناصره لاسرائيل وقد راوا ا هذا الرفض
القاطع لسيناريو التهجير يعني بداوا
يقولوا لا ما لا لا مش لكن لا استبعد على
الاطلاق ان يكون هذا مجرد رد فعل لعدم
اثاره غضب الدول العربيه فالسيناريو الاول
انهم يخلصوا من غزه اصلا وده متعثر على
الاقل في الوقت الحالي وده متعثر تماما في
الوقت الحالي السيناريو الثاني انه
اسرائيل
تجد احنا احنا يعني هي المساله واضحه
تحاول اقناع السلطه ان تاتي من رام الله
وتمد سلطتها كما تتمنى السلطه اصلا وتمد
سلطتها على غزه طيب سيناريو السلطه
الفلسطينيه عليه
ملاحظات اولا يعني انا اشك ان السلطه
الفلسطينيه اذا حدث ل قدر الله سيناريو
الهزيمه في في غزه في هذه الجوله انها سوف
تقبل ببساطه ان تذهب الى غزه
وتحكمها لانه هذا معناه ان السلطه التي
بعدت عن غزه على الاقل منذ 2007 حتى الان
تدخل اليها يعني
كسلطان سمعته للرئيس محمود عباس كان يتحدث
عن منظمه التحرير الفلسطين الفلسطينيه
باعتبارها مسؤوله عن الشعب
الفلسطيني ولكن هذا لا يمكن ان يح يحدث
الا في اطار ترتيبات جديده تضمن الاستقلال
او تضمن حل القضيه الفلسطينيه منظمه تحرير
الفلسطينيه لا يمكن ان تحكم غزه بالنيابه
عن اسرائيل او بدون افق سياسي فضلا عن
نقطه في منتهى الاهميه كان من المعروف انه
ما زالت حماس خارج المنظمه واعتقد انه من
المستحيل ان تحكم منظمه تحرير الا
الفلسطينيه من الان فصاعدا سواء في الضفه
او في غزه بدون وحده وطنيه فلسطينيه بس
سامحنا معالي الدكتور انا برده مش قادر
يعني ارى الخط ما بين ما يجب وامنيات
حضرتك وما تتمناه ان يحدث وبين
السيناريوهات احنا كان عندنا سيناريو
التهجير ده واضح وده الان متعثر السيناريو
الثاني ان اسرائيل تقول لسلطه والامريكان
يقولوا للسلطه انتم مسؤولين عن كل الشعب
الفلسطيني وانتم خرجتم من غزه في 2007 بعد
انقلاب او بعد حرب او بعد صدام من فصيل
عليكم وبالتالي لماذا لا تعودوا
فالسيناريو ده وارد انه يتحقق او
لا يعني اولا اريد ان اذكر بان سيناريو
2007 اتى بعد انتخابات
ديمقراطيه فازت فيها حماس انا لست منحازا
لحماس انا منحاز لحماس كفصيل تحرر وطني
انما حماس فازت بالانتخابات التشريعيه في
في عموم فلسطين وكونت الحكومه في بعد
انتخابات 2006 ولذلك انا متحفظ
على لفظ انقلاب هو حدث تداعيات بعد تكوين
وعلى فكره حماس عرضت على منظمه التحرير او
على السلطه الفلسطينيه ان تشارك في حكومه
ائتلافيه والسلطه رفضت وحدث ما حدث من
صدام وا الى اخره امر لا نقبله ولكني اؤكد
على فكره انه لا يمكن ان تتولى السلطه
الفلسطينيه الحكم في غزه وفي القطاع بعد
طوفان الاقصى بدون النجاح في تحقيق الوحده
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه وانا لا احلم انا لست
مثاليا انا مدرستي في العلاقات الدوليه
المدرسه الواقعيه لكن المقاومه الفلسطينيه
قدمت ما يثبت انها صاحبه قوه يعني احنا
الان شهر كامل المقاومه الفلسطينيه تواجه
الجيش الاسرائيلي مدعوما بتدخل عسكري
امريكي جاهز عشان لو الحرب اتسع اتسعت
مدعوما باسلحه خرافيه تمدها بها الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه مدعوما بقوات خاصه لا
ادري مدى مشاركتها في القتال لكن على
الاقل هي تقدم دعما استشاريا وفنيا ده غير
بقى خدمات المعلومات والاقمار الصناعيه
وما الى هذا شهر كامل فصائل المقاومه في
غزه بتقاوم في اسرائيل الا يكفي هذا
اثباتا ان المقاومه لديها من القوه ما
يجعلنا ناخذ يعني رؤيه الشعب الفلسطيني
لمستقبله وتحرره ا في الاعتبار سيقال انها
قد هزمت لكنها هزيمه مؤقته لماذا نقبل
بالدنيه ونحن متاكد طب ما احنا لو بنفس
المنطق كنا بعد حرب 67 مدينا ايدينا
لاسرائيل وقلنا لهم خلاص يلا نتفق وفرضوا
علينا ما تشاء لا خدنا حرب
استنزاف بعد اسابيع من هزيمه 67 وحتى حرب
اكتوبر
وصحح الميزان عظيم بس انا برض اوكي ما انا
مش احنا مش مختلفين على الاحراج بتقولوا
الان بس انا بقول ان احنا يعني احنا بناقش
او موضوعنا الرئيسي السيناريوهات في حاله
هزيمه المقاومه ففي حاله هزيمه المقاومه
كان ملف التهجير موجود هذا متعثر في كتله
جغرافيه وفي كتله بشريه يجب ان تحكم
السيناريو الثاني ان اسرائيل والولايات
المتحده وهم بداوا بالفعل اقناع السلطه ان
تاتي فهو السيناريو ده في حاله عدم وجود
حماس احنا بنتخ يعني حماس هزمت هتيجي
السلطه وتبدا ان هي تبقى موجوده في قطاع
غزه وتبتدي تتفاهم مع الموجودين هل هذا
السيناريو عمليا يصعب تحقيقه ولماذا يصعب
تحقيقه ان لم يكن يستحيل تحقيقه اولا كلنا
يعلم مشاكل السلطه الوطنيه في الضفه مع
اسرائيل السلطه الوطنيه الفلسطينيه لا
تحكم الضفه بالمعنى
الفعلي نتابع في كل يوم وفي كل لحظه
القوات الاسرائيليه التي تخترق اي مكان في
الضفه الغربيه فتهدم المنازل وتعتقل الناس
وتقتلهم وبالتالي هل هذا هو ما ستفعله
السلطه الوطنيه في غزه هي عملته في الضفه
ما تعملوش في غزه ليه هي عاملاه في الضفه
من سنين ما حدث طب وهل هذا
صحيح ح الضف صحيح ما حدث في الضفه لا يمكن
ان يتكرر في غزه بعد طوفان الاقصى اذا لم
تستطع السلطه الفلسطينيه ان تفرض افقا
سياسيا لدورها الجديد في غزه لا يمكن ان
تقوم اي سلطه فلسطينيه سواء السلطه
الحاليه او اي سلطه اخرى يتفقون عليها لا
يمكن ان يقوم ان تقوم بدور ناجح لا في
قطاع غزه ولا في الضفه بدون افق سياسي ما
هو هذا الافق السياسي هو الاستقلال زوال
الاحتلال اذا لم يعجبهم عندنا دايما سلاح
الرفض هو يا معالي الدكتور حتى لو خدنا
الوضع ما قبل 7 اكتوبر ما كانت ما كانش في
افق للحل غير ان غزه مستقره بما هي عليه
يعني مقاطعه محاصره موجوده بفصيل بيحكمها
الفصيل ده بتحصل معاه مناوشات واحتكاكات
من وقت لاخر مع اسرائيل وكانت الامور
موجوده يعني لو لم تستفز اسرائيل المقاومه
بشكل عنيف كانت هتبقى هنفرد حماس بحكم
القطاع وتظل السلطه احكم تحت الاحتلال في
الضفه فما الغريب ما هذه هي قيمه طوفان
الاقصى انه اثبت ان الهدوء وان طال لابد
له من نهايه انا يمكن سبق قلت لا ادري في
لقاء مع حضرتك ولا في لقاء اخر قلت ان انا
شخصيا جه علي وقت تصورت ان حماس قبلت بهذا
الوضع وانها تسوي اوضاعها وتكيف اوضاعها
مع نتنياهو لكن درس طوفان الاقصى ان اي
استقرار يحدث في سواء في قطاع غزه او في
الضفه او في اي تجربه استعماريه هو
استقرار مؤقت طب ما هي فرنسا احتلت
الجزائر سنه
1830 وحدثت موجات متباينه من مقاومه الشعب
الجزائري الى ان وصلت الذروه في 1 نوفمبر
1954 وحققه الاستقلال في ثمان سنوات اذا
ومن لا يعجبه هذا المنطق ف يبقي على الوضع
الراهن ويريني او ير او يري جيلا قادما
كيف سيمكنه ان يديم الاحتلال الى الابد
انا عاوز استاذن حضرتك ان انا اصيغ
المساله على هذا النحو فكره حضرتك
المركزيه اللي انت بتقولها دلوقتي وفي
حلقات سابقه واضحه وهو انه المقاومه دايما
بتنتصر وان طال المطال هذه واضحه فكره
حضرتك انه صعوبه حكم غزه لاسرائيل السابقه
او واضحه فكره التهجير وفشلها واضحه احنا
بنتكلم على سيناريو ليس على
اهميه طوفان الاقصى احنا فهمناه ولا عن
مبرراته احنا بنتكلم على فكره
السيناريوهات في حاله هزيمه المقاومه في
عندنا كتله لازم تحكم السيناريو اللي
موجود حضرتك بتستعد ان السلطه تاتي لانه
لن يتقبل اهل غزه السلطه لا ممكن يتقبلوها
بس لن يتقبلوها بدون افق سياسي الشعب في
في غزه او اهلنا في غزه عندما تاتيهم
السلطه الفلسطينيه بدون افق سياسي ماشي من
ممكن تحكم شهر شهرين سنه سنتين لكن ستعود
الامور سيرتها الاولى وبقول لحضرتك احنا
في ايدنا سلاح الرفض يا سلطه مين احنا يا
مع دكتور احنا احنا الفلسطينيين واحنا الع
فلسطينيه لم ترفض اي شيء السلطه
الفلسطينيه عد 30 يوم حتى الان هي بتكتفي
موقفها على فكره الكلام ده انا انا مش
عايز اكون فضي والله بس هو مدى 30 يوم لو
كان للسلطه شئت قدمه لقدمت الخيارات اللي
قدام السلطه عمليا لم تفعل منها شيئا بما
فيها حل السلطه بما انها لا تفعل شيء
السلطه لم تقدم شيء الدول العربيه
مساهمتها محدوده جدا فاحنا بنتكلم مين
احنا بنتكلم في سيناريو هزيمه المقاومه
هيبقى قدامنا واحد ان تاتي السلطه حك
بتقول ده
صعب صعب بدون افق سياسي وعايز برض اتحفظ
بقول ان السلطه الصينيه صحيح لم تفعل شيئا
بمعنى انها لم تدعم المقاومين في غزه
لكنها على الاقل تفهمت العمليه لم تدن
مثلا ما قامت به حماس في طوفان الاقصى ده
الاتحاد الاوروبي في بعض جوانبه فعل ذلك
تمام بعد القوى بعد يعني بعض السياسيين في
في امريكا فعلوا ذك يعني شوف يا استاذ سيد
هو هذا السيناريو سواء السلطه الفلسطينيه
او غيرها اذا حدث اذا حدث لا انه انا لا
استطيع ان افصل هل سيحدث ام لا اذا حدث لن
ينجح ات تمام ونملك احنا نملك يعني
كفلسطينيين وكسلت فلسطينيه وكعب نملك ان
نضع فيتو على هذا السيناريو اذا معالي
الدكتور مره ثانيه لو حبيت الخص اللي
حضرتك قلته يعني وارجو ان تصح ان لو اخطات
انت حضرتك بتقول ان في حاله هزيمه
المقاومه التي تستبعدها او على الاقل تقول
انه من المبكر ان نجزم بذلك وبنستر لسنا
واحد انت بتقول اللي بيستعدوا لسيناريو
واحد وهزيمه المقاومه واهمون لكل الاسباب
اللي حضرك طرحتها في هذه الحلقه وفي حلقات
سابقه لكن اذا سلمنا جدلا ان ذلك حدث وان
المقاومه هزمت مؤقتا حضتك بتقول ان
السيناريو الاول وهو التهجير قد فشل
السيناريو الثاني ان تاتي اسرائيل
بقوى فلسطينيه خانعا سواء اقنعت السلطه او
غير السلطه بان تاتي باي سلطه بتقول هذا
السيناريو يصعب ان يتحق
لانه هتتكرر نفس المشكله يعني سلطه
فلسطينيه مدعومه من احتلال فتثور المقاومه
مره اخرى في غزه بالضبط بالضبط كده هذا هو
التسلسل الطبيعي للاحداث واعتقد ان ما حدث
في الشهر الاخير وعندما نضعه في الافق
التاريخي شوف حضرتك يعني لو اخذنا بعد
س محطات كده معركه الكرامه سنه 68
العمليات السبعينات اللي كان عليها بعض
الملاحظات ثم انتفاضه الحجاره من ديسمبر
87 الى ما قبل الغزو العراقي للكويت
وبعدين انتفاضه الاقصى التي تفجرت في 28
سبتمبر 2000 واستمرت حتى اجبرت المقاومه
بننسى ليه حتى اجبرت المقاومه يريل شارون
في قطاع غزه انه ينسحب من طرف واحد بل
ويفكك المستوطنات المحيطه بغزه ونحن الان
بعد قد ايه بقى بعد دلوقتي خمسه من 23
يعني 18 سنه اه والجولات المختلفه عدوان
اسرائيل على غزه اواخر 2008 2009 عدوانها
في 2012 في 14 في 18 في مايو الماضي مادي
مايو 23 اذا يعني خبره التاريخ شديده
الوضوح لا نهايه المقاومه مهما بلغت وحشيه
المحتل اذا لا يعجبهم منطقنا يتفضلوا هم
يورونا ويحكموا غزه طب هل في سيناريوهات
اخرى مطروحه يا معالي الدكتور يعني
متداوله مممكن تكون
موجوده لا ما هو هو يعني اما اما ان تتولى
اسرائيل المسؤوليه كسطه احتلال وفي هذه
الحاله نهارها سيكون اسوا نهار ممكن واما
ان تاتي بهيكل فلسطيني ما يحكم غزه في هذه
الظروف وهو ما اشك فيه كثيرا وحتى لو
اوجدت ودي على فكره
يعني سمه في الممارسات الاستعماريه يعني
بريطانيا لما ضاقت بها السبل في جنوب
اليمن في اواخر مرحله التحرر الوطني في
الجنوب عملت حاجه اسمها اتحاد الجنوب
العربي ولا اي حاجه كيان هش وسقط يحكم
بالنيابه عن بريطانيا يعني
يتولى المسؤوليه عشان لو بريطانيا انسحبت
تضمن البتاع كيان هش وانهار في اول فرصه
ممكنه
وفرت بريطانيا من جنوب اليمن على فكره
حاله جنوب اليمن دي حاله فذه ان بريطانيا
تقريبا هربت من امام قوات الجبهه القوميه
وتم الانسحاب بدون لا اتفاق ولا مفاوضات
ولا شيء من هذا القبيل فيعني يعني خبره
التاريخ شديده الوضوء
اذا جه حد يريد ان يحكم فلسطين غزه من
الفلسطينيين هذا السيناريو لن يعمر على
الاطلاق وبالتالي انا بقول اذا لم نستطع
كفلسطينيين وكعب ان نرفض سيناريوهات حكم
غزه لصالح اسرائيل عشان يعني تعلم اهلها
الادب يعني اذا لم نستطع هذا خلاص هذه
افعالكم تحملوا مسؤوليتها مش انتوا دمرتوا
غزه وقتلت عدد يزيد الان عن 100 الا شهيد
من ابناء غزه خلاص افضلوا تولوا المسؤوليه
وورونا هتعملوا ايه وعموما الولايات
المتحده واللي بيتابع الكواليس تسريبات لا
تتوقف عن انه هناك خلافات بين الولايات
المتحده
واسرائيل على عده مستويات واحد منها ان
الولايات المتحده بتقول لاسرائيل ليست
لديك رؤيه سوى الغضب انت غاضبه والغضب ليس
سياسه بعد ضرب غزه وبعد اعمال كل هذا
العنف ضدها ليس لديك رؤيه لمستقبل غزه بعد
توقف المعارك بقت حماس ذهبت حماس يجب ان
يكون لديك رؤيه واسرائيل بتبحث عن رؤيه
اعمل ايه في القطاع بعد ما بعد اذا نجحت
في ضرب حماس اسرائيل لا تعلم انا متاكد
لان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه فيها عقول
عاقله فيها ناس عاقلين زي ما فيها ناس
بيرددوا كالببغاوات مقولات الساسه
الاسرائيلين متطرفين هناك ناس في منتهى
الاحترام وتحليلات في منتهى الاحترام داخل
اسرائيل نفسها اذا تتبعنا الصحافه
الاسرائيليه هناك اراء في منتهى الاحترام
لكن مشكله
الولايات متحده في مع اسرائيل ان هي
يعني ترجوها تدللها تلفت نظرها لكنها لا
لا لا تجبرها وفي مث مثل عامي مصري انا
اسف ان انا اقوله في لقاء كهذا بيقول يعني
عامل زي ضرب الغازيه في حمارها يعني انه
كده يعني بلاش يعني عشان بس خاطر صحتك
بلاش تعملي كده والوى اخره لا هناك افكار
وبدات تنعكس على تصريحات مسؤولين امريكيين
كبار قبل ما اجي لحضرتك صباح اليوم يعني
النهارده تسريب من في لموقع بوليتيكو وهو
موقع محترم يعني
انه
الصفوف المتوسطه والاقل من المتوسطه في
الخارجيه لديها حاله غضب من سياسه الرئيس
بايدن تجاه اسرائيل والغضب ده على محورين
واحد انه يجب ان يكون اكثر حزما في فرض ا
وقف لاطلاق النار اثنين لا يجب ان يتردد
عن انتقاد ما يصح الانتقاد على صعيد
الممارسات الاسرائيليه وبيعتمد الجمهور
الغالب يعني او الغالبيه ده داخل وزاره
الخارجيه انه ده مش بس لاسباب اخلاقيه
ولكن ان ده بيضر بمصالح امريكا ويظهرها
كدوله منافقه و غير امينه يعني فهذا عن
الموقف الامريكي مع الدكتور يعني على فكره
يعني وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه تاريخيا
كانت تمثل صوت العقل في حالات كثيره اللهم
الا عندما تولاها وزراء يعني لا يعلم بهم
الا الا الله طيب هذا عن الموقف الامريكي
وهذا عن السيناريوهين الاساسيين لحضرتك
قلت ان هم كلاهما صعب انه تاتي السلطه بان
تاتي اسرائيل بسلطه خانع وتقول ان ده
هيكون يعني هيكون تكرار لنفس المقاس
السابقه وهتف عليها المقاومه بعد حين وانه
الاقرب بقى انه اسرائيل لا تجد من يحكم
بالنيابه
عنها وبالتالي تاتي الى تاتي الى غزه
ويتكرر نفس مقاسي الاحتلال مع غزه اللي
اضطرت تنسحب منه في 2005 كما انسحبت من
جنوب لبنان تحت ضغط المعارضه طيب احنا
عندنا مؤتمر قمه هيكون يوم 11 بعد بضعه
ايام احنا بنسجل الحلقه يوم 7ب تخيل حضرتك
في ايجاز وحضرتك تبعت القمم العربيه على
مدار سنوات في ايجاز تتخيل ماذا يمكن ان
تقدم هذه القمه في علاج او في يعني في شان
حرب غزه اذا
حكمت بما حدث حتى الان من موا
للدول
العربيه فيها اختلافات واضحه فاني اتصور
انه نتائج القمه الطارئه
لن تقوم بالدور المطلوب منها في دعم
الموقف الفلسطيني كما ينبغي ما اتمناه انه
وارجو انه من هنا اليوم 11 يعني يكون هناك
من التطورات ما يقنع القاد المجتمعين في
القمه انه ما لم يحدث يعني تغير نوعي في
ردود الفعل العربيه ولو على الصعيد ولو
على صعيد الخطاب السياسي لان هناك سلاح
البعض بيستهتر بيه ان ارفض الهزيمه يعني
السيناريو اللي بنقوله ان اسرائيل تريد
منا ديكورا سياسيا في غزه لكي يعني يحكم
غزه لحساب اسرائيل ابسط شيء اذا لم نستطع
فرض ارادتنا نرفض هذا لا احد سيحاسبنا
وبالتالي انا باختصار شديد يعني اتصور انه
نتائج القمه ستكون معتدله وانا في ذهني
مثال تاريخي هي القمه العربيه في سبتمبر
1982 بعد الغزو الاسرائيلي للبنان الحقيقه
لا اريد ان اذكر تفاصيل لكن يعني هي
معروفه يا متور اذكر التفاصيل ليست على
المستوى فانا اتمنى لا بس في بعض اللي
بيتابعو ما كانش اتولد سنه 82 فقول لنا
باختصار شديد ما حصل في 822 عقده القمه
امتى قالت ايه لا ما هو 82 غزت اسرائيل
لبنان امتى في يونيو متى عقدت القمه
العربيه في سبتمبر
يعني خرج في اغسطس ا اظن اه لان بيروت
قاومت حوالي
88 يوم ثم خرج عرفات حتى لا ينسب اليه
تدمير
بيروت وبعد كده
فيعني يعني ان شاء الله لا تتكرر سابقه
قمه سبتمبر
1982 استاذن حضرتك يعني اوضح لاصدقائنا
المتابعين اللي ربما يكون المثال ما كانش
واضح ليهم وحضرتك صحح ني ان كنت انا اخطات
اللي حصل انه اسرائيل غزت لبنان في يونيو
82 واظن كان الهدف الرئيسي اخراج الفصائل
الفلسطينيه المسلحه اللي كانت بتسبب لها
صداع بدا الغزو الدمار كان عنيف جدا اختار
ابو عرفات
في الزعيم ياسر عرفات لاسباب يطول شرحها
ان يخرج هو والفصائل المسلحه الى تونس في
اخر اغسطس 82 تونس واليمن
82 عقدت القمه العربيه لتدارك اثار
العدوان الاسرائيلي على لبنان في سبتمبر
في سبتمبر في سبتمبر 822 اي بعد العدوان
بحوالي ثلاث شهور وبعد تحقق تحقيق العدوان
الهدف منه وده اللي انا بشعر ان حضرتك
متحرج انك تقوله صراحه يعني لا لا بس نقطه
مهمه جدا ما انا يعني كويس ان حضرتك طرحت
هذا المثال لان دي نقطه مهمه جدا انه مش
بس اسرائيل دخلت لبنان دي عملت معاها
اتفاق سلام فرض على اللبنانيين
1983 لم يعمر لسنه صحيح الغاه مجلس النواب
اللبناني وبعدين الكلام ده كان سنه 82 طب
ماذا حدث في الثمانينات نمو المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وصعودها وانها اخذت في التصاعد
حتى اجبرت اسرائيل على اولا المقاومه
اللبنانيه المباشره اجبرت اسرائيل على
الخروج من لبنان يعني بعد وقت وجيز من
احتلال لبنان واحتفظت بالشريط الجنوبي
الذي احتلته في
1978 لكي تضطر مجبره على الخروج منه بليل
في مايو 2000 جزيل الشكر معال الدكتور وان
شاء الله الحوار موصول عن الاوضاع في غزه
وقضايا اخرى عربيه شكرا لحضراتكم ونلقاكم
في حلقات اخرى باذن الله